what's going on guys this is Rob if you
guys enjoy my content make sure you hit
the subscribe button and make sure you
hit that little bell so you never miss
out on my sexy voice
okay guys so we are getting back into
the story of William Stryker really to
crusade now here's the deal
we did the first part of the story a
month ago and that's the nature of us
doing the x-men chronology remember this
is an x-men chronology it's not just one
of the comic book lines after the events
of house of M when you know 98% of the
mutants lost their powers and all we had
were a hundred ninety eight mutants left
Marvel kicked off decimation and
decimation runs through like new x-men
and x-men vol 2 and uncanny x-men and
all these different things and so when
we're doing it in a chronological order
what this means is we'll cover a story
like we did you know with children you
know childhoods end which will be
William Stryker launching an attack
against a busload of innocent kids and
that's where it drops off that's the
cliffhanger that it leaves us on and
then it'll be like a month and a half
before we get back to that now there's
also another way that we can do this
what we can do is we can go through
individual stories like story arcs you
know I'm sorry on individual comic lines
because Marvel will segue this this
whole thing this whole decimation
that'll go into endangered species which
is basically a one shot and a whole
bunch of backup features and what we
could basically do is we can do all the
new x-men comics and then all the
uncanny x-men comics and then all the
x-men to comics and that will allow us
to kind of like run through the whole
story of things without you know ending
on a cliffhanger that we don't revisit
for like you know two months but it also
allows us to get into those you know
those events the problem is will
reference stories or world will cover
stories that'll reference events that we
haven't covered yet but I'll leave it to
you guys in terms of what you want to do
because I was going through the comments
section for childhood and childhood and
and people were just like why did you
leave us on a cliffhanger and again
that's what we pick up with this video
right I mean this video dealt with the
return of William Stryker really the
last video dealt with the return of
William Stryker the idea that William
Stryker had basically shown up and he
was this guy who had really gone all the
way back to Chris Claremont with God
loves man kills the whole base concept
of William Stryker is that he is a man
who believes is his mission from God to
kill mutants so those are the guys who
were watching the TV show gifted take
the character of dr. Campbell erase all
the science replace it with evangelical
Christian beliefs and then that's
William Stryker now the whole idea
behind this was that William Stryker
returned through unknown means we didn't
well not really he returned I mean he
was just kind of cast out and it
basically been living as a homeless guy
but the idea here was that he had
attained some kind of power through
unknown means for whatever reason and by
whatever means
William Stryker was able to know when
people were going to die and then in
turn stop that from happening the other
half of this is that it was all hinting
at a greater plan well God has a plan
for all of you and so the implication
here is that William Stryker has powers
now that seemed to be the idea and
that's one of the things that made him
so dangerous is because if he's able to
see the future that makes him more
dangerous and he's never been because it
means now he can start launching
campaigns and basically defeat the
mutants before they even have an idea of
what's going on now remember in the post
house of M landscape a lot of groups are
vying for the destruction of them you
know what's left to the mutant
population Friends of humanity fringe
anti-mutant groups whatever but William
Stryker and the purifiers are the most
dangerous because they are believers
William Stryker believes God wants him
to kill Newtons and the purifiers will
follow whatever he tells them to and
they cannot be wavered not only that
when William Stryker blew up that bus
the initial response you know with this
whole thing picking up and this funeral
is oh my god you know they lost some
humans in that catastrophe that's a
terrible thing what we end up finding
out here is it wasn't just one who died
42 kids were casualties of this act of
William Stryker and that's why that
whole thing kicking off that way is
designed to be that way
Craig cow Chris Yost they knew what they
were doing when they jumped into this
whole thing of William Stryker
historically speaking with William
Stryker believing is his mission from
God he believes that he is immune to any
kind of vengeful punishment he will do
whatever it takes
there is no limit to how hardcore he
will get in order to achieve his goal
when he comes along and he says it's
time for me to start killing mutants
he'll do he'll kill anybody and that's
why him blowing up a busload of kids was
designed to hit at that it's extreme
it's heinous it's a horrible thing to do
but it's designed to hit at the nature
that's what William Stryker does not
only that but we end up finding out is
that we're 42 of these kids were taken
out 15 are being buried at the Xavier
Institute because their parents didn't
want them there their parents didn't
want to have anything to do with him now
the other half list is remember there's
Jay Guthrie and Jay Guthrie was
basically this kid who had effectively
walked away you know he would he just
kind of abandon the x-men for a time you
know and then basically reappeared
without his wings and because of the
fact that he was Icarus you know because
of the fact that it's designed that when
it the idea that Icarus quote-unquote
flew too close to the Sun and as wax
wings melted this is really designed to
hint at the nature of that because neo
Jay's healing factor is tied into his
wings and so with his wings having been
removed in their entirety
he has no healing factor in effect Jay
Guthrie's human now and so what we end
up doing is we end up picking up with
you know what
Streicher talking to his purifiers only
for us to find out that the next target
and the omega-level threat among all the
x-men the one that we're really shooting
for is Joshua Foley a character known as
a lexer now this is important for a
couple different reasons one because
elixir is an omega-level character I
mean he could basically manipulate the
biological structure of matter but this
is one of those things that we talked
about when we cover like our Omega
beyond Omega level series this is one of
those things that we talk about where we
say and they were references being Omega
level in this comic this is what we mean
for the most part when it comes to
characters when it comes to mutants to
me a lot of people know this but we'll
run over for the people who don't know
you know there are basically really
Omega Alpha level beta level OBO beyond
Omega level threats all those things
that exist out there now in truth the
term Omega level predates Grant
Morrison's new x-men run by a couple
decades in fact I think Chris Chris
Claremont used it way back when but it
was just kind of a thrown out it was
kind of a throw out thing of hey there
Omega level meaning like they're
powerful Grant Morrison grabbed that
concept expanded on it and created a
classification system for mutants in his
new x-men run and that's why people
usually attribute that to Grant Morrison
the result is that Joshua Foley is an
Omega level threat meaning he's one of
the most powerful mutants in existence
but the important thing to keep in mind
here is that William Stryker going after
Joshua Foley is not based strictly on
the fact that he's a lick sir it's also
because of the fact that he plays a very
important role presumably Stryker knows
this because God told him so and so what
we do here is we pick up with the
training of this new group of x-men now
this is very very important because what
you have is basically again you know
this amazing sniper you know this guy
who's two and a half miles away
basically keeping an eye on what's going
on with regards to the x-men and really
with regards to these sentinels design
for the purpose of just kind of you know
disabling them and so on and so forth
and that's what these is what the
purifiers are doing that's why Stryker
Gotham together in such a way Stryker
brought these guys together because they
all have a very particular set of skills
sets one guy is a surgeon another guy is
a world-class assassin and another guy
is a computer hacker who's almost
completely unrivaled and that's the idea
is to use the technology of that guy or
at least seeming to use the technology
of that guy to take down all these
sentinels now what we also end up
finding out here is that William Stryker
is using another source now if you guys
have read this please don't like please
don't spoil this for anybody who hasn't
seen it because this is the return of
one of the best villains ever in the
history of the x-men comics but we don't
initially know who this is
all we know is just that somebody is
there that can tap into all four
Machinery and manipulate them and so
using this being who's basically been
hacked into you buy this purifier that
William Stryker recruited they in turn
power down all the sentinels now
remember these sentinels are human
piloted through the office of national
emergency sentinels and they were put
here because the federal government
responded to the massive reduction in
the mutant population and said look
we're gonna stationed ourselves at the
Xavier Institute no one gets in no one
gets out we're gonna keep the x-men
protected but we're also not gonna let
them leave that's kind of the the the
crazy thing about this but the training
of these new mutants is actually a
throwback to the old Age of Apocalypse
line of stories because in that altered
reality when apocalypse had basically
conquered North America you ended up
having like this new generation etch
line of stories where you ended up
having Illyana Rasputin and her brother
or maybe was Kitty Pryde I think it was
Kitty Pryde and her and her boyfriend
husband at the time Colossus training
this new generation of x-men and they
were ruthless I mean they were hardcore
and it's designed to be that way I mean
this instance right here this training
segment is designed to be hardcore
they're facing off against Colossus now
Colossus is tough but if they're
struggling against Colossus what hope do
they have against the other threats that
are out there and that's the message
that's being conveyed here Joshua Foley
elixir arguably the most powerful person
here x-23 dust I mean you have all these
really really powerful beings but all of
them are struggling against Colossus and
that's the point that Emma Frost makes
this is Colossus and you're struggling
against him what hope do you have if
like apocalypse decides he wants to
invade the Xavier Institute which he
will what happens what if someone like
magneto decides to invade if juggernaut
appears that's what Emma Frost is
hitting yet there have been so many
villains that the x-men have had to face
off against that they have struggled
against and these kids are struggling
against Colossus and that's the whole
thing
what choice do you guys have what chance
do you have here and that's why this
training is so significant is because as
Emma Frost basically coming along and
saying okay your childhood is now over
like you are in a position now where you
are going to become the new generation
of x-men and either you can make it or
you can die and those are the only
options that you have that's why this is
so huge and so important is because what
we end up doing is picking up in the
aftermath of all this you know with
regards to Jay himself what's really
hinted at is that for him as Jay Guthrie
that he had at some point along the line
set these events in motion or at least
you know it's really kind of believed
that he
did and so he ends up actually traveling
to go meet Suraiya somebody says look
we've been friends for an exceedingly
long time but I have to go fix this you
know and when I do I want you to know
that everything's gonna be ok but you
have to come with me somewhere along the
line and he gives her an address to this
place you know 221 North Main Salem
Center and basically says look come
along and meet me here sometime now for
Joshua Foley himself because of the fact
that during the training session he had
lashed out and he had attached Colossus
when he wasn't looking basically
attacked a teacher when their guard was
down the idea was that he was
effectively removed from the team now
this is Emma Frost basically saying look
one you need some time to cool down but
two I want to put you in a position
where mentally you have a desire to
return to the team because right now
it's anger because he's a healer he's
one of the most powerful healers in
existence but in his mind he should have
been able to save the kids who died and
he couldn't he wasn't able to pull it
off and so he feels like a failure and
because he feels like a failure he's
trying to find a way to vent that anger
and he's actually internalizing it and
so on only the only way for him to
really come to grips with this is to
have time to cool down but for Emma
Frost to also talk to him as well but
what he ends up doing is kind of
storming off only for you know one of
the characters Laurie to basically come
after him and say look you can't just
take off like this you got to come back
you got to calm down those kids are not
your fault the problem is that in the
middle of all this Laurie's assassinated
she's shot and killed by the sniper
who's watching everything unfold and
that's when William Stryker makes his
move when you have Jay Guthrie who shows
up we end up finding out that William
Stryker was the one that had his wings
removed and that he had gone to William
Stryker somewhere along the line so
Laurie's out of the picture wallflower
is gone for some reason or another
that's not initially given to us
wallflower is going to stand in the way
of the motivations of William Stryker
and keep his actions from happening and
so with her out of the picture now it's
let's make our move we're going to
attack the Xavier Institute while their
guard is down it's a very complex plan
not only that what we end up finding out
here is that this goal that William
Stryker is able to achieve and his
ability to quote unquote see the future
that all comes by the return of one of
the most powerful beings in existence
Nimrod the ultimate Sentinel now burn
limitation okay Nimrod love Nimrod of
the character Nimrod is the ultimate
Sentinel from the Days of Future past in
the future of the Days of Future past
timeline the Sentinels they were
evolving themselves and what they did is
their ultimate creation was was nem'ro
now Nimrod ended up leaving the Days of
Future past on line and traveling to the
main Marvel Universe when he did Nimrod
clean house the x-men had
no idea how to cope with Nimrod and
that's a crazy thing I mean he was
defeated ultimately but with Nimrod as
the ultimate Sentinel let's say that
like you're in a battle with Nimrod and
by some miracle you happen to like break
the indestructible outer shell of Nimrod
he'll reconstitute himself in seconds
not only that one of the biggest
benefits of Nimrod has is the ability to
not only know what the mutant powers of
various xmin are gonna be because he's
from the future but also he has this
ability to analyze what those powers are
and figure out the weakness of the
person that he's fighting and so that's
the whole idea here is that when William
Stryker was just kind of making his way
before the MD event happened when 98% of
mutant mutant sloths to power he was
suddenly met by the arrival of a
time-displaced Nimrod and when this
Nimrod crashed basically I kind of shut
down in collapse William Stryker brought
him back to the church and started
recruiting all these different people to
his cause and what we ended up having
was William Stryker using these
different hackers and so on and so forth
to look through the minds eye of Nimrod
and see the Days of Future past but
where most people would look at Days of
Future past and see it as just a
horrible outcome William Stryker saw
perfection a place where mutants were
all wiped out of existence
none of them existed they had all been
destroyed but for William Stryker he's
so fanatical and so insane that in his
mind even though humans were being
subjected in the same capacity as
mutants work at the end of the day the
main target was mutants and mutants were
the main ones who were being wiped out
or being put to use as servants and so
in the mind of William Stryker that's
the perfect future not only that what we
end up finding out is the reason why
William Stryker was able to go to each
one of these individual people and
basically rescue them from like a car
crash or from like a you know a plane
explosion or something along those lines
is because he had used the knowledge of
the future from-from Nimrod to look and
see which one of these individuals was
going to be the most important to his
scheme which ones he could use and then
save them before they died all the while
passing it off as God's knowledge and so
this is when Jay is basically given the
truth of the situation that when he
appeared at William Stryker and William
Stryker said I will save your friends I
will bring you guys to a path of a great
and beautiful life what are you saying
is I will send you to God and God will
send them to hell because they are
demonic spawn that's the whole
perception of William Stryker it's
dubious but at the end of the day that's
the goal he wants to achieve and so at
this point we switch back over to Surya
who had basically again received that
message from Jay where you know he
basically said look coming
with me Lord Kimmy's responses don't go
because it's a trap and when the
question is asked well how do you know
that lures responses well that's what I
would do if I were trying to find a way
to take you out I would lead you to a
place where you're going to be
defenseless or your powers can be
neutralized and then I would kill you
and so that's the whole thing because
the xmin are trying to figure out what
in the world is going on and how all
this kicks in not only that we actually
end up having Williams strike or show
Jay Guthrie the future that when your
striker is shooting for the future where
William Stryker launches his attack
against all the x-men in the Xavier
Institute the future where all these
characters were all these different
people that Sam Guthrie knows well
they're all taken out they're all
eliminated and they're all killed that's
the future that William Stryker is is
loving and that's the future that Jay
didn't realize William Stryker was
looking for and so because of the fact
that Jay is effectively to set up all of
his friends to die and a massive
onslaught that William Stryker is
getting ready to unleash well you end up
having Sariah show up suddenly serratus
Araya is shot to pieces and the initial
thing that we end up seeing is that
where they're looking to the future and
they're saying okay so like these
characters should basically disappear
from the future landscape subtly suryya
starts to go away and then we end up
having Jay Guthrie who's shot by William
Stryker it's cold blooded
it's ruthless but that is William
Stryker that's why I love his character
so much there's so much character
development with William Stryker because
he's just a god but because of his
knowledge of the x-men because of how
many resources he's devoted into
bringing down the x-men and mutant kind
he's so capable and in fact he takes one
of the arms of Nimrod and invades the
Xavier Institute because all the signals
have been shut down and none of the
x-men know it's coming the office of
national emergency is supposed to be
their protection if you're Emma Frost
sure you've got you know psychic
barriers that are out there to notice
whenever people are showing up but
they're only there if you have a reason
to put them up but if you never had a
reason to believe that anybody was
coming
well then suddenly there's no reason to
be concerned about that and so what is
up happening here is that where you end
up having some of these guys who show
out to take the body of suryya
to basically dispose of it what we end
up learning is that this is not suryya
this is Laura Kenney this is x-23 I read
this and I was like hell yeah girl look
get on a girl cuz like she starts
tearing these guys apart like magic huh
does she rip these guys to pieces they
were not prepared that's exactly what
happens she tears these guys apart not
only that at the same time the Nimrod
Sentinel goes online and starts killing
off all these purifiers now the initial
response of Nimrod is there is a mutant
here
his name is J Guthrie he must not but
the problem is at the amount of
discharge the amount of energy it would
take to obliterate J Guthrie would
basically ease out whatever energy
Nimrod currently has now memorize in a
position where it has to ask itself this
question do I use my energy to achieve
my primary goal or do I use this energy
to achieve the secondary goal of
eliminating State Guthrie well then when
he analyzes M he realizes J Guthrie is
basically bleeding to death he's gonna
die anyway and so he takes off to
basically go find the the particular
goal or the one particular person that
he's tracking down this is important
because what it means is Nimrod is alive
and well in the x-men universe right now
and under normal circumstances we would
basically say all hope is lost here and
so following this you have the purifiers
who break in to the Xavier Institute
they are all prepared they have mental
blocks in place designed to basically
hold off against various threats that
are there not only that when one of them
goes after Emma Frost Emma Frost does
have a secondary mutation that allows
her to turn into a diamond form the
problem with this Emma Frost diamond
form does not allow her to use her
telepathy at the same time and so she
could turn back into a normal into her
normal form and users Halawa the-- but
the question that has to be asked is
this can she beat this girl can Emma
Frost
turn back into a human form and then
invoke her telepathy to defeat this
chick before that chick just stabbed her
to death is that a possibility even then
there's no guarantee that Emma Frost
telepathy would work on this girl
because she might have mental blocks and
places on to keep that telepathy from
happening and that's exactly what she
says butyl epithelia feck tuss and so of
course because of the fact that this is
a vibranium blade it's made to stab
through some of the most durable and
materials in the Marvel Universe it cuts
right through Emma Frost diamond form
and this girl just starts taking her out
now of course this leads to things like
like Hellion jumping in and saving Emma
Frost yeah but that's the crazy thing is
because while all this is happening
you basically have Forge who's working
on this whole scenario with regards to
creating like a sentinel of sorts is
designed to capitalize on the office of
national emergency their technology and
so on and so forth there's protocols
that are being uploaded to protect
mutants and different things like that
but this is cool because it really kind
of hinted the idea of like what other
mutants are doing while all this is
going on keep in mind
deadly Genesis is happening at the same
time this story is happening so that's
why you don't see Cyclops here that's
why you don't see Wolverine here is
because they're all off doing deadly
Genesis they're all off bo dealing with
Vulcan and that whole thing and so this
is kind of cool because in this instance
you've got Forge who's basically a
mutant with the intuitive ability to
understand how things work whose work
on a project of his own you know some
need to basically benefit the x-men at
the same time you end up having sera
waking up you know being able to use her
ability to manipulate San and just tear
these guys to pieces different things
like that a lot of these folks are
stepping in where they can when they
can't but it's really like mass panic
you essentially have a scenario where
William Stryker and the purifiers
managed to deactivate the office of
national emergency assembles deactivate
all the security protocols around the
Xavier Institute sneak into the building
and take all these mutants by surprise
and then use all their knowledge of
weapons and tactics to start taking them
all out and so what happens it all comes
down to Joshua Foley a character that
has the ability to heal who does not
have a strong understanding of his
powers literally seizes the mind of
William Stryker and essentially just
manipulates the entire biological
structure of William and essentially
kills him on the spot the problem is
that we still have Joshua Foley learning
how to use his powers so we don't know
what the effect of this is yet or at
least for the sake of this video we
don't know what the effect is yet we
don't really know what it's going to do
to his character he's just kind of stuck
in this catatonic state but with the
return of Cyclops and you know most of
the x-men after all this has happened
and basically saying okay look we'll try
to get the pieces back together kind of
move on from the death of a lot of these
younger x-men what we end up finding out
is that with the Nimrod signal that the
primary objective is to find its maker
and what we end up finding out is the
maker of Nimrod is actually Forge
himself but with that being said guys
we're gonna bring this video to an end
if you are new here - comments explained
make sure you guys have the sub button
to become part of the Rob core if you
guys enjoy this video make sure you drop
a like and the next story arc for this
is called Nimrod so yeah let me know
what you guys want to do with regards to
those storylines different things like
that you know how we're gonna arrange
these comics and I will catch you all
later peace
you